actually permanently lost ground is an
issue for the UK but here's here's the
slightly scary one okay this is now what
the bank of England thinks we're heading
for just look at that line and look at
how different the shape is compared with
last time and remember that with these
lines the higher they are the better off
we're all doing the lower they are well
you know it's the opposite you know
we're not in a good place when those
lines are basically kind of flatlining
now there are question marks about
whether that bank of England forecast
that was just a couple of weeks ago
where that bank of England forecast can
be relied upon but even so we're
probably more likely to see something a
bit more like this from the office for
Budget responsibility today and remember
these are the official forecasts we get
from the government upon which
everything else is based so looking at
shapes like that is actually going to
help us to get a sense of what's going
on one other kind of chart that we have
looked at quite a lot recently haven't
we uh is the pound and you know back
there I was I was saying just that then
you know we didn't expect did we at the
start of that day that we're going to be
spending so much time looking at Market
charts this is a market chart basically
on how valuable the pound versus the US
dollar we're going back to the 14th of
September just because I want to show
you a bit of the um recent history there
was the mini budget the higher this is
the more the pound is worth by the way
that's the mini budget 21st September
and just look at the plunge afterwards
so that was the moment we were in the
studio talking about just how the pound
was falling but then it continued to
fall over the course of that weekend and
look at where it ended up record low
against the US dollar just above uh one
dollar and getting close to parity you
know we've never seen anything like that
worse than in 1985 the plaza record
worse than anything we've seen since
well 1776 the invention of the the
dollar us independence and then we saw
things change obviously so Liz trust
resigning quasi quateng resigning as
well and the pound has been
strengthening ever since then it's not
just a pound story it's worth just
underlining that um there's a lot of
other things going on right now the
dollar has been very strong recently as
well but even so these charts whether
it's the pound whether it's government
bond yields are the kinds of things that
the government is going to be paying
quite a lot of attention to and the
final thing I want to just note because
this this again underlies everything
else
is that question of a black hole
remember you've heard probably quite a
lot about there being a black hole in
the public finances that needs to be
sorted out what is that black hole well
this is basically it okay this is the
national debt okay this this big area
here and we're looking out into the
future here aren't we okay so 2023 on
onwards and what you can see is last
time the obr did its forecast it's not
that long ago in March but it feels like
you know an age away that was falling
very gradually but it was falling as a
percentage of GDP in the next few years
that all changed with the mini budget so
look at that line look at how this
suddenly becomes a rising shot of the
rising national debt and the rationale
in the treasury the rationale you'll
hear about from Jeremy Hunt is you need
to basically eliminate that so the
national debt is falling rather than
gradually rising and that is basically
where the black hole comes in it's you
know it's quite simple here but remember
that's a concept you know it's not a
definitive black hole it's what the
government would like to do in other
words to have that falling over the next
five years
and that in turn will involve
potentially spending cuts tax increases
of getting up towards about 50 60
billion pounds so that's that's the big
picture Sophie and you know when you
look at some of these charts when you
look at what they're faced with that
underlines why we're going to be hearing
kind of quite miserable tone from Jeremy
Hunt and and others
but I mean you know this has changed a
lot over even over the course of the
last few weeks it was going to be just a
fiscal update it was going to be a kind
of relatively small statement now you
know this will potentially set the tone
for the next five years of both
economics and politics so it's a big
deal it really brings me back to when
the three of us were here eight weeks
ago as well looking at your charts I'm
not sure our Jaws lost left the floor at
that day I wonder if we'll have a bit
more of a sense I think about what to
expect later today thank you both very
much we'll be back with you in a moment
but let's bring in Sky's Dan Whitehead
shall we who is at Bristol's Saint
Nicholas Market where Traders are
waiting to hear how the Chancellor's
announcement will affect their
businesses Dan what are they telling you
yeah morning Sophie we've been in and
around Bristol uh all morning speaking
to members of the public they're worried
about their energy bills they are
worried about their taxes but of course
businesses as well as you say we're
instant Nick's Market they're setting up
for the lunchtime trade this is one of
the busiest Food Markets here in the
City of Bristol and we're going to chat
now to Sam from The Olive Works uh one
of the busiest stores here Sam and um
you were talking about how you've
actually had to make changes let's just
talk about at the minute what what are
the problems that the business faces in
all the businesses here in terms of
costs what's gone up for you
pretty much everything I would say
um I think that the craziest one for us
is the produce that we're buying in see
from our boards up there we've had to
make made changes to the menu just
because of how expensive stuff is lots
of sort of tip X and paint That's gone
over it yeah things have had to be taken
off and also prices have had to go up as
well so stuff like lamb we don't sell
that anymore which is one of our biggest
sellers it's just it's just too
expensive yeah yeah the price is almost
doubled so what about bills and
everything like that uh bills thankfully
I'm not really in charge of them but we
know they're just Rising along with
everything else as well just quickly can
you pass on these costs because I know
that in about an hour's time you will
have cues going down here so people are
still coming have you noticed any
difference in what people order or the
number of people
um definitely a change in how much they
spent extra stuff like drinks they just
don't really buy anymore
but I mean business has still been all
right yeah it's just and I notice you've
got two two signs here staff needed
that's pretty much across the board here
everyone's looking for staff aren't they
in Hospitality well if you know anyone
that wants a job to have been their CV
in but yeah it's a bit of a bit of a
dangerous let's just walk down here
thanks Sam thanks so much let's chat to
Abdul who's at one of the other stalls
here as I say look you do get a lot of
tourists they're still doing the trade
um but uh Abdul uh if we can just have a
quick chat because I know that you're
also setting up here a lot of curries on
the go and you're saying that you're
also noticing a pressure on your your
bottom line your costs yes it's getting
better what's what's the squeeze been
for you it's been like you know we'd
like to meet you know I mean we you know
it's going up Sky you know it's very
very expensive and the vegetables
electric you know everything went up you
know the chancellor Jeremy Hunt is going
to deliver this awesome statement in the
next half an hour what would be your
number one priority for the government
to help you
electric electric so you want that
energy cap price yeah extended we think
that might be on the on the cards is
that a big help for you yeah it does
yeah it's electric is a big things you
know I mean we used to pay like 300 now
we come 600. you need to pay 300 pounds
so you're still here now 600 600 but
everything went up probably were you
able to pass these costs on to the the
customers here at lunchtime uh yeah
not much you know but you know the
things change you know sometimes you
know we want to put the prices up people
is not happy about it you know but all
the course of inspired
how are you feeling about going into
next year are you optimistic or are you
worried a bit worried
what did winter come in
and then everything and people I don't
think you can afford to go out his
outside as well you know I mean even
though the price is very low people
still complain
Abdullah I'll let you get back because I
know everyone is setting up here for the
uh the lunchtime trade I think for a lot
of people and speaking to some of the
customers here as well it's about how
much of a buffer zone that they have
they've seen their energy prices go up
uh they've seen a bit less in their pay
packets and with inflation at a 41 year
high how much more can people take how
much more can the businesses take before
that buffer zone that people have if
they have it if they're fortunate to
have it stops and they don't they can't
squeeze any more out of that monthly pay
so a lot of people public and the
businesses will be giving a Keen Eye on
the chancellor in the next 50 minutes or
so yeah they certainly will uh not long
to wait now as well just around 10
minutes ago until the chancellor it
takes to his feet well we can go down to
Skies Sally Lockwood who's in
Wolverhampton for us today where
business owners and Shoppers are also
awaiting the Chancellor's announcement
nervously uh Sally it's exactly the kind
of electoral Battleground that both the
conservatives and labor are going to be
looking at the reaction to What is the
sense where you well
I was certainly the cost of living is
very much in the Forefront of people's
minds here Wolverhampton has a strong
industrial Heritage we're actually in
the headquarters of chub locks which was
built more than 120 years ago but it was
renovated as a retail space back in the
1990s and certainly they're already
seeing the first shoots of recession
here at a cinema which has been open in
this building for 30 years closed
exactly two weeks ago today and I'm
joined Now by two business owners who
have a business in this building Craig
speed and Daniel Wright they're both
from a railway maintenance company
called empro thanks so much for joining
us now your business has been around for
about five years you employ around 40
people how is business at the moment
well I mean it's buoyant for us we we
went through the pandemic and we
actually grew but obviously like any SMA
at the moment we're concerned about the
future what the the budget announcements
mean to our costs and our ability to
retain the right staff and and serve our
contracts and and make profit on what we
do and what we
are what we're doing today from the
chancellor is tax Rises spend cuts we're
going into a recession what's the
outlook for you
so um in terms of rail as well as
uncertainty in rails so the Outlook is
that projects that we might have been
awarded or that we tended for some time
ago 12 months ago might yet not have not
yet mobilized and similarly our costs
have gone up since we put those
proposals in but we don't have an
opportunity to raise our prices and
obviously our customers the train and
Freight operators they're facing down
with pressure to cut costs so we have to
hold our prices whilst our costs
themselves have gone up so as we've
already touched on remunerating the
staff we might assume given labor rates
a year ago we're having to pay a lot
more than that now to retain those
people and that puts pressure on our on
our profits cast your minds back to just
eight weeks ago a mere eight weeks ago
the quasi-quarting budget under the very
briefly trust Administration as business
owners how did you feel about that that
was focused on growth obviously yeah I
mean you know as I say as a owner of an
SME you know reducing of corporation tax
and and things like that will you know
will will help us with our our operation
but by the same token you know I think
we we didn't see it potentially
sustainable or necessarily right for the
country and in terms of your workers
you've got around 40 staff uh inflation
is a huge issue uh people on low
-con lotion how are they are they at the
moment
so so obviously we've got some really
good teams from Scotland down to the
south coast and we want to retain those
people so we're aware
um that they might not be knocking the
door at the moment but we're
anticipating conversations about
um pay Awards pay reviews and obviously
we want to retain good people and and
look after our best people so you know
we're anticipating those costs coming
forward and as I say the
there's not really an opportunity to
increase our prices we have to hold our
prices so we'll be absorbing that but
yeah we're waiting for those
conversations to start okay Daniel Craig
thank you so much for speaking to us we
wish you well certainly they're already
very worrying reports about how people
are struggling to cope here people who
have cut themselves off from the power
grid altogether because they're so
worried about paying their energy bills
and research last month showed that one
in five people in the West Midlands in
the poorest areas are already skipping
meals trying to make ends meet certainly
people in regions like this want to be
heard down in Westminster today
yeah well not too long to find out
whether or not their voices will be
Sally thank you so much for bringing us
that update from uh Wolverhampton uh
we'll be talking about uh what voters
think what the Electoral think let's
talk a little bit now shall we on how
the Autumn statements like just go down
with the business Community we can talk
now to our business presenter in King
who is in the city for us in what are
you watching for
well uh Sophie I'm in uh Ed Conway took
you through some of the uh fiscal
arithmetic earlier on I mean very little
uh tends to happen in the equity markets
on the budget day really is going to be
all about what happens in the bond
markets the UK government guilt market
and indeed to a lesser extent the
foreign exchange markets uh Sterling of
course has traded at a three-month high
in the last week against US dollar
that's partly down to Dollar weakness
but there's no doubt that the scare that
we had after the mini budget has uh has
been put in at bains somewhat and that's
certainly true in the market for UK
government bonds government guilts uh
guilt yields which of course are an
implied government borrowing cost have
come down pretty significantly if you
take the 10-year guilt well the yield on
that now is currently just north of 3.1
percent it's actually lower than it was
in the days going into the mini budget
so to that extent all of the market
Panic that you saw uh post uh
quasi-quarters mini budget has uh has
Unwound the question is uh whether you
can keep yields down and that is really
what the market will be looking from
from Jeremy Hunt today don't forget that
uh in the next few years government the
cost of servicing the national debt
meeting interest payments on the
national debt is going to be north of uh
100 billion pounds a year it's going to
consume a tenth of the government's
Revenue if you think back only a few
years ago uh Sergeant Javid who the Lost
Chancellor but three uh he tried to set
that at six percent so there's clearly a
big big increase in government borrowing
costs so to that extent if you can get
the deficit done more rapidly than
anticipated well ultimately that is all
to the good in the longer term for broad
the broader business Community Sophie
well I think people will want to hear a
bit more about growth because obviously
the main focus of what we're getting on
today is all about uh sorting out the
fiscal position and getting the
government borrowing down in the longer
term but of course you can't just cut
your way to growth and that is something
that businesses have been arguing for
some time there are a lot of measures
that the business world would like to
see in terms of enhancing productivity
whether that is for example loosening
the planning regulations addressing
business rates which is a real bug bear
for a lot of businesses right now
there's been very little indication from
uh Jeremy Hunt that uh business rates
reform is going to be uh on the agenda
it is of course something that the labor
party has pledged to look at and that is
a real area that would certainly help
businesses out another is on the ease
with which uh businesses can hire
migrants workers uh we've got a very
very tight labor market right now the
level of unemployment is is at a 48 year
low there's a massive skill shortage a
lot of business is very very concerned
about that so that is something that
they would uh hope to see address today
I suspect they uh they shouldn't hold
their breath to be honest with you
I think you may be right there Ian thank
you very much for the update from the
city we'll have more from in uh as we
get more details on the Autumn statement
and at 4 30 you can ask your own
questions on how the Autumn statement is
likely to affect you because we're going
to be holding a q a with the personal
finance expert Gemma Godfrey that's at 4
30 this afternoon live on Sky News worth
putting your questions in because the
one thing we do know is that this is an
Autumn statement that is going to be
impacting every single one of us well
myself Beth and Ed will have all eyes on
the chamber in the House of Commons you
can see it there now Boris Johnson is in
the chamber we understand also Theresa
May you might even be able to pick her
out in a bright orange jacket awaiting
to hear from the uh Chancellor as we all
are and we are going to be taking you
straight to that statement just as soon
as he gets to his feet in the meantime
Beth
um
there's been some consternation hasn't
there been from some conservative MPS
already uh talking is he on his feet
there I'm just having a quick look
it looks like
nope we sat down again it's a false
alarm not yet we'll be back with you as
soon as he does as MP's Scurry to take
their seats it's always packed on these
days isn't it how much a consternation
do you think there may be from the
benches uh Beth that if we are going to
see the level of tax Rises that we're
expecting well look there's a number of
conservatives particularly those in the
Liz truss Administration that have
warned against tax Rises but I think one
thing that the chancellor will do is
that he will operate pensions in line
with inflations and he will upright
benefits in line uh with inflation the
argument has been from Rishi sunak and
Jeremy Hunt that they want to be
compassionate and fair so that they hope
that that will alleviate some concerns
on the benches but there's no doubt that
the likes of Simon Clark are key Liz
truss Ally the likes of Jacob Reese MOG
they believe that there shouldn't be as
many as much tax taxation as there is
and they would rather have spending cuts
and that will be a big a big test and I
think the big sort of debate really and
the thing I'd be watching for today is
there is a fragile truce at the moment
between Rishi sunak and the Liz
trussites and people in the party that
didn't much want Rishi suno to be prime
minister and don't much like this
package of economic measures and the
question will be in the coming weeks can
the truce still hold or are the
divisions gonna open up again let's
listen to the chancellor
Mr Speaker
in the face of unprecedented Global
headwinds families pensioners businesses
teachers nurses and many others are
worried about the future so today we
deliver a plan to tackle the cost of
living crisis and rebuild our economy
our priorities are stability growth and
public services
we also protect the vulnerable because
to be British is to be compassionate and
this is a compassionate
[Music]
we are not alone in facing these
problems
but today we respond to an international
crisis with British values
we are honest about the challenges
and we are fair in our Solutions yes we
take difficult decisions to tackle
inflation and keep mortgage rates down
but our plan also leads to a shallower
downturn lower energy bills higher
growth and a stronger NHS and education
system
[Applause]
three priorities then today
stability growth and public services
I start with stability
Mr Speaker High inflation is the enemy
of stability it means higher mortgage
rates more expensive food and fuel bills
businesses failing and unemployment
Rising it erodes savings causes
industrial unrest and cuts funding for
public services it hurts the poorest the
most and eats away at the trust upon
which a strong Society is built
the office for Budget responsibility
confirms Global factors are the primary
cause of current inflation
[Applause]
most countries are still dealing with a
Fallout from a once in a century
pandemic
a furlough scheme the vaccine rollout
and the response of the NHS did our
country proud
but they all have to be paid for the
lasting impact on Supply chains has made
Goods more expensive and fueled
inflation and this has been met worsened
by a made in Russia energy crisis
[Applause]
Putin's war in Ukraine has caused
wholesale gas and electricity prices to
rise to eight times their historic
average
inflation is high here but higher in
Germany the Netherlands and Italy
interest rates have risen here but
faster in the U.S Canada and New Zealand
growth forecasts have fallen here but
Fallen further in Germany the
international monetary fund expect one
third of the world's economy to be in
recession this year or next so the bank
of England which has done an outstanding
job since its independence now has my
wholehearted support in its mission to
defeat inflation and I date today
confirm we will not change its remit
but we need fiscal and monetary policy
to work together
and that means the government and the
bank working in lockstep it means in
particular giving the world confidence
in our ability to pay our debts
British families make sacrifices every
day to live within their means and so
too must their government because the
United Kingdom will always pay its way
I understand I understand the motivation
of my predecessor's mini budget and he
was correct he was correct to identify
growth as a priority
unfunded tax cuts are as risky as
unfunded spending which is why we
reversed the plan measure
as a result
government borrowing has fallen the
pound has strengthened and the obr says
today that the lower interest rates
generated by the government's actions
are already benefiting our economy and
public finances
[Music]
speaker credibility cannot be taken for
granted and yesterday's inflation
figures show we must continue a
Relentless fight to bring it down
including a rock-solid commitment to
rebuild our public finances Richard
Hughes and his team at the obr today lay
out starkly the impact of global
headwinds on the UK economy and I'm
enormously grateful to him and his team
for their thorough work
the obr forecast the UK's inflation rate
to be 9.1 percent this year and 7.4
percent next year
they confirm that our actions today help
inflation to fall sharply from the
middle of next year
they also judge that the UK like other
countries is now in recession
overall this year the economy is still
forecast to grow by 4.2 percent
GDP then Falls in 2023 by 1.4 percent
before Rising by 1.3 percent 2.6 and 2.7
percent in the following three years
the obr says higher energy prices
explain the majority of the downward
Revision in cumulative growth since
March
they also expect a rise in unemployment
from 3.6 today to 4.9 in 2024 before
falling to 4.1 percent
today's decisions mean that over the
next five years borrowing is more than
halved this year we're forecast to
borrow 7.1 percent of GDP or 177 billion
pounds next year 5.5 percent of GDP or
140 billion pounds then by
2027-28 it falls to 2.4 percent of GDP
or 69 billion pounds as a result
underlying debt as a percentage of GDP
starts to fall from a peak of 97.6
percent in 2025 6 to 97.3 percent in
2728
I also confirmed two new fiscal rules
the first is that underlying debt Must
Fall as a percentage of GDP by the fifth
year of a rolling five-year period the
second that public sector borrowing over
the same period must be below three
percent of GDP and the plan I'm
announcing today meets both rules
today's statement delivers a
consolidation of 55 billion pounds and
means inflation and interest rates end
up significantly lower
we achieve this Mr Speaker in a balanced
way
in the short term as growth slows and
unemployment Rises we will use fiscal
policy to support the economy
the obr confirmed that because of our
plans the recession is shallower and
inflation is reduced
unemployment is also lower with about 70
000 jobs saved as a result of our
decisions today
then once growth returns we increase the
pace of consolidation to get debt
falling this further reduces the
pressure on the bank to raise interest
rates because as conservatives we do not
leave our debts to the Next Generation
[Applause]
so Mr Speaker this is a balanced path to
stability tackling inflation to reduce
the cost of living and protect pensioner
savings while supporting the economy on
a path to growth
but it means taking difficult decisions
anyone who says there are easy answers
is not being straight with the British
people
some
some argue some argue for spending cuts
that that would not be compatible with
high quality Public Services
others say savings should be found by
increasing taxes but conservatives know
that high tax economies damage
Enterprise and erode Freedom we want low
taxes and sound money that conservatives
know sound money has to come first
because inflation eats away at the pound
in people's pockets even more
insidiously than taxes
so with just under half
of the 55 billion pound consolidation
coming from tax and just over half from
spending this is a balanced plan for
stability
I turn first to our decisions on tax
I have tried to be fair by following two
broad principles firstly we ask those
with more to contribute more and
secondly we avoid the tax Rises that
damage growth although my decisions
today do lead to a substantial tax
increase we have not raised headline
rates of Taxation and tax as a
percentage of GDP will increase by just
one percent over the next five years
I start with personal taxes
asking more from those who have more
means that the first difficult decision
I take on tax is to reduce the Threshold
at which the 45p rate becomes payable
from 150 000 pounds to 125 140 pounds
those earning 150 000 pounds or more
will pay just over 1200 pounds more in
tax every year
we're also taking difficult decisions on
tax-free allowances
by maintaining at current levels the
income tax personal allowance higher
rate threshold main National Insurance
thresholds and the inheritance tax
thresholds for a further two years
taking us to April 2028
even after that
we'll still have the most generous set
of tax-free allowances of any G7 country
I'm also reforming allowances on
unearned income the dividend allowance
will be cut from two thousand pounds to
one thousand pounds next year and then
to 500 pounds from April 24. the annual
exempt amount for capital gains tax will
be cut from twelve thousand three
hundred pounds to six thousand pounds
next year and then three thousand pounds
from April 24th these changes still
leave us with more generous allowances
than countries like Germany Ireland
France and Canada
because the obr forecast half of all new
vehicles will be electric by 2025 to
make our motoring tax system fairer I've
decided that from then electric vehicles
will no longer be exempt from vehicle
excise duty company car tax rates will
remain lower for electric vehicles and
I've listened to Industry bodies and
will limit rate increases to one
percentage point a year for three years
from 2025.
the obr expects housing activity to slow
over the next two years
so the stamp Duty Cuts announced in the
mini budget will remain in place but
only until the 31st of March 2025 after
that I will sunset the measure creating
an incentive to support the housing
market and the jobs associated with it
by boosting transaction During the
period the economy most needed
I now turn to business taxes
while I've decided to freeze the
employer's next threshold until April
2028 we will retain the employment
allowance at its new higher level of 5
000 pounds this means 40 percent of all
businesses will pay no Nicks at all but
that threshold is already more than
twice as high as the EU and oecd
averages I will maintain it at that
level until March 26th
my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister successfully negotiated a
landmark International tax deal to make
sure multinational corporations
including big tech companies pay the
right tax in the countries they operate
I will Implement these reforms making
sure the UK gets our fair share
alongside further measures to tackle tax
avoidance and evasion this will raise an
additional 2.8 billion pounds by 2728
I've also heard concerning reports of
abuse and fraud in r d tax relief for
smes
so I've decided today to cut the
deduction rate for the SME scheme to 86
and the credit rate to 10 percent but
increased the rate of the separate r d
expenditure credit from 13 to 20 percent
despite raising revenue the obr have
confirmed that these measures have no
detrimental impact on the level of r d
investment in the economy
ahead of the next budget we'll work with
industry to understand what further
support r d intensive smes may require
windfall taxes
I have no objection to windfall taxes if
[Applause]
if in Energy prices
but but
I know the honor worms obviously getting
excited at the talk of windfall taxes
can I just say that any such tax should
be temporary not to deter investment and
recognize the cyclical nature of energy
businesses so taking account of this
I've decided that from January the 1st
until March 28 we will increase the
energy profits Levy from 25 to 35
percent the structure of our energy
Market also creates windfall profits for
low carbon electricity generation so
from January the 1st we've decided to
introduce a new temporary 45 levy on
electricity generators together these
measures raise 14 billion pounds next
year finally finally I turn to business
rates
it's an important principle that bills
should accurately reflect Market values
so we'll proceed with the revaluation of
business properties from April 23 but I
will soften the blow on businesses with
a nearly 14 billion pounds tax cut over
the next five years nearly two-thirds of
properties will not pay a penny more
next year and thousands of pubs
restaurants and small High Street shops
will benefit this will include a new
government-funded transitional relief
scheme as call for by the CBI the
British retail Consortium the Federation
of small businesses and others
benefiting around 700 000 businesses Mr
Speaker our plan for the cost of living
delivers lower inflation lower mortgage
rates a shallower downturn and lower
unemployment
but it also involves public spending
discipline
so I turn next to how we protect Public
Services through a challenging period
his vision for this country has at its
heart a strong NHS and world-class
education
we know that a strong economy depends on
strong public services so we will
protect them as much as we can as we
deliver our plan for stability and
growth
we do have to take difficult decisions
on public finances
so we're going to grow public spending
but we're going to grow it more slowly
than the growth in the economy
for the remaining two years of the
spending review we'll protect the
increases in departmental budgets we've
already set out in cash terms and then
grow resource spending at one percent a
year in real terms in the three years
that follow
although departments will have to make
efficiencies to deal with inflationary
pressures in the next two years
this decision means overall spending in
public services will continue to rise in
real terms for the next five years
[Music]
before I turn
before I turn to our plan for schools in
the NHS I start with two other areas of
spending
the department for work and pensions has
a critical role in supporting people
into work and I am proud to live in a
country with one of the most
comprehensive safety nets anywhere in
the world
but I am also concerned that we've seen
a sharp increase in economically
inactive working age adults of around
630
000 people since the start of the
pandemic employment levels have yet to
return to pre-pandemic levels which is
bad for businesses who cannot fill
vacancies and bad for people missing out
on the opportunity to do well for
themselves and their families so the
prime ministers asked the work and
pension secretary to do a thorough
review of issues holding back Workforce
participation to conclude early in the
New Year
alongside this I am also committed to
helping people already in work to raise
their incomes progress in work and
become financially independent so we
will ask over 600 000 more people on
Universal Credit to meet with a work
coach so that they can get the support
they need to increase their hours for
earnings
I've also decided to move back the
managed transition of people from
employment and support allowance onto
Universal credits of 2028 and we'll
invest an extra 280 million pounds in
DWP to crack down on benefit fraud and
error over the next two years and the
government's review of the state pension
age will also be published in early
2023.
our security at home depends on our
security overseas
so I turn next to defense and other
International commitments
the privilege of being this country's
foreign secretary showed me firsthand
the enormous respect in which this
country is held because the United
Kingdom is and has always been a Force
for good in the world
[Applause]
men and women who risk their lives every
day in defense of our territory and our
belief in Freedom alongside them I
salute the citizens of another country
right on the front line of that fight
today the brave people of Ukraine
the United Kingdom has given their
Military Support worth 2.3 billion
pounds since the start of Putin's
Invasion the second highest contribution
in the world after the United States
which demonstrates that our commitment
to democracy and open societies remains
steadfast in that context the Prime
Minister and I both recognize the need
to increase defense spending
but before we make that commitment it's
necessary to revise and update the
integrated review written as it was
before the Ukraine Invasion and I've
asked for that vital work to be
completed ahead of the next budget and
today confirm we will continue to
maintain the defense budget at least two
percent of GDP to be consistent with our
NATO commitment
another important International
commitment is to overseas aid the OBS
forecasts show a significant shock to
public finances so it won't be possible
to return to the 0.7 Target until the
fiscal situation allows
we remain fully committed to that Target
and the plans that I've set out today
assume that odor spending will remain
around 0.5 for the forecast period as a
percentage of gni we were the third
highest donor in the G7 last year and I
am proud our Aid commitment has saved
thousands of lives around the world
so I look forward to working closely
with my right honorable friend the
member for southern coalfield now
rightly back in his placing cabinet to
make sure we continue to play a
leadership role in tackling Global
poverty
the United Kingdom has also been a
global leader on climate change cutting
emissions by more than any other G20
country
but with the existential vulnerability
we face now would be the wrong time to
step back from our International climate
responsibilities so I also confirm that
despite the economic pressures
we remain fully committed to the
historic Glasgow climate-packed agreed
at cop 26 including a 68 reduction in
our own emissions by 2030.
I turn to education
Mr Speaker
be education is being pro-growth
but providing our children with a good
education is not just an economic
Mission it's a moral mission one to
which my right honorable friend the
Prime Minister has always been deeply
committed
thanks to the efforts of
its location secretaries particularly my
right honorable friends from Surrey
Heath and from bognor Regis we have
risen nine places in the global League
tables for maths and reading in the last
seven years
[Applause]
I still however have concerns that not
all School leavers get the skills they
need for a modern economy
but for the first time ever this country
has a conservative education secretary
who left school at 16 to become an
apprentice and knows firsthand why good
skills matter
there are many important initiatives in
place but as Chancellor I want to know
the answer to one simple question will
every young person leave the education
system with the skills they would get in
Japan Germany or Switzerland so I have
appointed
so I've appointed Sir Michael Barber to
advise me and my right honorable
friendly education secretary on the
implementation of our skills reform
program
raise the skill levels of our school
leavers
I want also to ensure that even in an
economic crisis the Improvement in
school standards continues to accelerate
some have suggested putting VAT on
independent school fees as a way of
increasing core funding for schools
which would raise about 1.7 billion
pounds but according to certain
estimates that would result in up to 90
000 children from the Independent sector
switching to State schools giving with
one hand only to take away with another
so
so so
instead of being ideological I'm going
to be practical
standards to continue to rise for every
single child we're going to do more than
protect the school's budget we're going
to increase it and I can announce today
but next year and the year after we will
invest an extra 2.3 billion pounds per
annum in our schools our message to
heads and teachers and classroom
assistants is thank you for your
brilliant work we need it to continue
and in difficult economic circumstances
a conservative government is investing
more in the public service that defines
all our futures
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the service we depend on more
than any other is the NHS
as a former Health secretary I know how
hard people are working on the front
line and how much they're struggling
after the pandemic
the biggest issues are Workforce
shortages and pressures in the social
care sector so today I address them both
on staff shortages the former chair of
the Health and Social care select
committee put forward a case for a
long-term Workforce plan he even wrote a
book about it which I've read
I've I've listened carefully to his
proposals and I believe
I believe they have merits so the
Department of Health and Social care and
the NHS will publish an independently
verified plan for the number of doctors
nurses and other professionals we'll
need in 5 10 and 15 years time taking
full account of the need for better
retention and productivity improvements
I've also listened to extensive
representations about the challenges
facing the social care sector
it did a heroic job looking after
children disabled adults and older
people during the pandemic
it's 1.6 million employees work
incredibly hard but even outside the
pandemic the increasing number of over
80s is putting massive pressure on their
services
I also heard very real concerns from
local authorities particularly about
their ability to deliver the dill not
reforms immediately
so I will delay the implementation of
this important reform for two years
allocating the funding to allow local
authorities to provide more care
packages
I also want the social care system to
help free up some of the Thirteen and a
half thousand hospital beds that are
occupied by those who should be at home
so I've decided to allocate for adult
social care additional grant funding of
one billion pounds next year and 1.7
billion pounds the year after combined
combined with savings from the delayed
deal not reforms and more council tax
flexibilities this means an increase in
funding available for the social care
sector of up to 2.8 billion pounds next
year and 4.7 billion pounds the year
after that's a big increase
but how we look after our most
vulnerable citizens is not just a
practical issue it speaks to our values
as a society so does today's decision
will allow the social care system to
deliver an estimated 200 000 more care
packages over the next two years the
biggest increase in funding under any
government of any color in history
[Applause]
the NHS budget
has been increased to record levels to
deal with the pandemic
and today I'm asking the NHS to join all
public services in tackling waste and
inefficiency
we want Scandinavian quality alongside
Singaporean efficiency both better
outcomes for Citizens and better value
for taxpayers
that does not mean asking people on the
front line often exhausted and burned
out to work harder which would not be
possible or fair but it does mean asking
challenging questions about how to
reform all our public services for the
better
so with respect to the NHS
I've asked former Health secretary and
chair of the Norfolk and Waverley
integrated care system Patricia Hewitt
to help me and the health secretary
achieve that by advising us on how to
make sure the new integrated care boards
[Music]
that operate efficiently and with
appropriate autonomy and accountability
I've also had discussions with NHS
England
about the inflationary pressures on
their budgets I recognize that
efficiency savings alone will not be
enough to deliver the services we all
need so because of difficult decisions
taken elsewhere today I will increase
the NHS budget in each of the next two
years by 3.3 billion pounds
the chief executor of the NHS Amanda
Pritchard has said that this should
provide sufficient funding for the NHS
to fulfill its key priorities
she said it shows the government is
serious about its commitment to
prioritize our NHS
3.3 billion for the NHS 4.7 billion
pounds for social care a record 8
billion pounds package for our Health
and Care system that is a conservative
government putting the NHS first
[Music]
and Mr Speaker
HS
and schools in Scotland the NHS and
schools in Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland face equivalent pressures so the
Barnet consequentials of today's
decisions mean an extra 1.5 billion
pounds for the Scottish government 1.2
billion pounds for the Welsh government
650 million pounds for the Northern
Ireland executive that is more resources
for the schools and hospitals in our
devolved Nations next year the year
after and every year thereafter
all right
Mr Speaker our support for public
services means that despite needing to
find 55 billion pounds in savings and
tax Rises we are protecting the amount
going into public services in real terms
over the five-year period
but if we're going to sustain our public
services and avoid a doom Loop of ever
higher taxes and ever lower dynoism we
need economic growth
so I now turn
I now turn well they've never been
interested in growth but we on this side
[Applause]
I want to get to the end of the budget
stream like the rest of the people of
this country Chancellor the ex Checker
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
so let's start with a difficult message
for the party offers that you cannot
borrow your way to growth
sound money is The Rock
sound money is the rock upon which
long-term Prosperity rests but it isn't
enough on its own our plan is designed
to build a highway High wage high skill
economy that leads to long-term
prosperity
in his May's lecture my right honorable
friend the Prime Minister identified the
keys to doing this people capital and
ideas
today's increase in the education budget
demonstrates our commitment to people
and skills and I now Outline Three
further growth priorities energy
infrastructure and innovation
cheap low carbon reliable energy must
sit at the heart of any modern economy
but Putin's weaponization of
international gas prices has helped
Drive the cost of our national energy
consumption right up
this year we'll be spending an extra 150
billion pounds on energy compared to
pre-pandemic levels equivalent to paying
for an entire second NHS through our
energy bills
in 2019 a third of global emissions came
from energy Supply
so unless we act radically to change our
approach we'll both bankrupt our economy
and harm our planet
over the long term there's only one way
to stop ourselves being at the mercy of
international gas prices energy
Independence combined with Energy
Efficiency
energy Independence so neither Putin nor
anyone else can use energy to Blackmail
us
and Energy Efficiency to reduce demand
and climate impact as much as possible
now Britain is a global leader in
renewable energy last year nearly 40
percent of our electricity came from
offshore wind solar and other Renewables
since 2010 our renewable energy
production has grown faster than any
other large country in Europe
but we need to go even further with a
major acceleration of homegrown
Technologies like offshore wind carbon
capture and storage and above all
[Music]
[Applause]
this will deliver new jobs Industries
and Export opportunities and secure the
clean affordable energy we need to power
our future economy and reach Net Zero so
today I can announce the government will
proceed with a new nuclear power plant
at seizewell soon
subject to final government approvals
the contracts for the initial
investments will be signed with relevant
parties including EDF in the coming
weeks
create 10 000 highly skilled jobs
and provide reliable low-carbon power to
the equivalent of six million homes for
50 years
700 million pound investment is the
first state backing for a nuclear
project in over 30 years and represents
the biggest step in our journey to
energy Independence
but Mr Speaker Energy Efficiency is just
as important
so today we set our country a new
National ambition
by 2030 we want to reduce energy
consumption from buildings and Industry
by 15
reducing Demand by this much means in
today's prices a 28 billion pound saving
from our national Energy bill or 450
pounds off the average household bill
this must be a shared Mission with
families and businesses playing their
part
but so will the government play our part
in this Parliament we're already
planning to invest in Energy Efficiency
a total of 6.6 billion pounds
today I'm announcing new funding from
2025 of a further 6 billion pounds
doubling our annual investment to
deliver this new National ambition our
commitments to the British people is
over time to remove the single biggest
driver of inflation and volatility
facing British businesses and consumers
so my right arm will find the business
and Energy Secretary will publish
further details on our energy
Independence plans and launch a new
Energy Efficiency task force shortly
Mr Speaker
if a modern economy needs secure clean
and affordable energy it also needs good
roads rail broadband and 5G
infrastructure
such connections matter because they
allow wealth and opportunity to spread
to every corner of the country
and that is why infrastructure is our
second growth priority
thanks to Decisions by this conservative
government right now workers right
across the country are building or
maintaining thousands of miles of roads
and Railways installing mobile masts and
Broadband cables to connect the remotest
parts of rural Britain building and
repairing hospitals and constructing new
wind turbines in the North Sea
when looking for cuts
capital is sometimes seen as an easy
option
but doing so limits not our budgets but
our future
so today I can announce that I'm not
cutting a penny from our Capital budgets
in the next two years and maintaining
them at that level in cash terms for the
following three years
that means
although we're not growing our capital
budget as planned it will still increase
from 63 billion pounds four years ago to
114 billion pounds next year 115 billion
pounds the year after and remain at that
level more than double what it was under
the last Labor government
foreign
[Applause]
countries build on their long-term
commitments rather than discard them so
today I confirm that because of this
decision alongside sizewell C we will
deliver the core Northern Powerhouse
rail hs2 to Manchester and East West
Rail and the new hospitals program and
gigabit Broadband rollout always all
these and more will be funded as
promised with over 600 billion pounds of
investment over the next five years to
connect our country and grow our economy
our national conservative mission is to
level up Economic Opportunity across the
country
needs in vestment in a structure so I
will also proceed with round two of the
leveling up fund at least matching the
1.7 billion pounds value of round one
will also Drive growth across the UK by
working with the Scottish government on
the feasibility study for the a75
supporting the advanced technology
Research Center in Wales and funding a
trade and investment event in Northern
Ireland next year
but to unlock growth
to unlock growth right across the
country we need to make it easier for
local leaders to make things happen
without banging on a White Hall door our
brilliant Mayors like Andy Street and
Ben Houchin
shown the power of Civic
entrepreneurship we need more of this
inspirational local leadership
so today I can announce a new Devolution
deal that will bring an elected mayor to
Suffolk and deals to bring Mayors to
Cornwall Norfolk and an area in the
Northeast to follow shortly
we're also making progress
we're also making progress
towards
towards Trailblazer Devolution deals
with the greater Manchester combined
Authority and West Midlands combined
Authority and soon over half of England
will be covered by Devolution deals
taken together
that 600 billion pounds investment in
our future vote growth
represents the largest investment in
public works for 40 years so our
children and grandchildren can be
confident that this conservative
government is investing in their future
energy and infrastructure
and now our third growth priority
innovation
Mr Speaker we have a national genius for
Innovation Britain is the land of Newton
Darwin Fleming Faraday Faraday Franklin
Gilbert and berners-lee the home of
three of the world's top 10 universities
the country with the largest Life
Science and Technology sectors in Europe
thanks to successive conservative
governments we remain a science
superpower
[Music]
and I salute the work of the former
Chancellor George Osborne my right
honorable friend from Tunbridge Wells
and my honorable friend the science
Minister member for Mid Norfolk for
laying the vital foundations to make
this possible
21st century economies will be defined
by new developments in artificial
intelligence Quantum Technologies and
Robotics
but we need to be better at turning
world-class Innovation into world-class
companies
so as a former entrepreneur I had to get
that in somewhere
to combine our technology and science
brilliance with our formidable Financial
Services to turn Britain into the
world's next Silicon Valley
we learned from the success of Nigel
Lawson's Big Bang in 1986. that smart
regulatory reform can spur investment
from all over the world
so today using our brexit freedoms I
confirm the next steps in our supply
side transformation
by the end of next year we will decide
and announce changes to EU regulations
in our five growth industries Digital
Life Sciences green Industries financial
services and advanced manufacturing and
I've asked the chief scientific officer
Sir Patrick Valance Who did such a
brilliant job in the pandemic to
our work on how to do this
the second lesson of Nigel Lawson's Big
Bang is the most important driver of
global Success is Not tax subsidies but
competition
so we will legislate to give the digital
markets unit new powers to challenge
monopolies and increase the competitive
pressure to innovate
to further spur competition I've
listened to requests from businesses and
today I'm removing import tariffs on
over 100 Goods used by UK businesses in
their production processes from car seat
parts to Bicycle frames I'll also change
our approach to investment zones which
will now focus on leveraging our
research strengths by being centered on
universities in Left Behind areas to
help build clusters for our new growth
industries am I right on refender
leveling up secretary will work with
mayor's devolved administrations and
local Partners to achieve this with the
first decisions announced ahead of the
spring budget
I've heard some speculation that we
might cut the research and development
budget today but I believe that would be
a profound mistake
in our 2017 Manifesto we announced the
targets to invest 2.4 percent of our GDP
in r d and the latest ons data suggests
the UK is close to meeting that Target
to go further so today I protect our
entire research budgets
that will increase Public Funding for r
e to 20 billion by 24.25 as part of our
mission to make the United Kingdom a
science superpower
and finally Nigel Lawson's Big Bang
inspires us today
but nearly 40 years on we must stay true
to its mission to make the UK the
world's most Innovative and competitive
Global Financial Center
so to further support investment across
our economy I also announced that we're
publishing our decision on solvency 2
which will unlock tens of billions of
pounds of investment for our growth
enhancing Industries
three priorities for growth energy
security investment in infrastructure
and a plan to turn the United Kingdom
into the world's next Silicon Valley
transforming British intellectual genius
into British commercial success
but alongside British genius
we must remember another great National
Quality British compassion
so this final part of our plan protects
the most vulnerable and it's to that I
now turn
to speak a strong public finances aren't
just to make accountants happy
it's because we took difficult decisions
in 2010 that we could afford record
funding increases for the NHS The
Landmark furlough scheme and now the
energy price guarantee
the day the discipline that we've shown
means we can provide targeted support to
help our most vulnerable citizens with
the cost of living
one of the biggest worries for families
is energy bills and I pay tribute to my
predecessor the right honorable member
for spellthorne and the former prime
minister the right honorable member for
Southwest Norfolk for their leadership
in this area
this winter we will stick with their
plan to spend 55 billion pounds to help
households and businesses with their
energy bills one of the largest support
plans in Europe from April we'll
continue the energy price guarantee for
a further 12 months at a higher level of
3 000 pounds per year for the average
household with prices forecast to remain
elevated throughout next year this will
mean an average of 500 pounds support
for every household in the country
at the same time for the most vulnerable
we'll introduce additional cost of
living payments next year of 900 pounds
to households or mean-tested benefits
300 pounds to pensioner households and
150 pounds for individuals on disability
benefit
we'll also provide an additional 1
billion pounds of funding to enable a
further 12-month extension to the
household support fund helping local
authorities to assist those who might
otherwise fall through the cracks
and for those households who use
alternative fuels such as heating oil
and LPG to heat their homes and today
doubling the amount of support from 100
pounds to 200 pounds which will be
delivered as soon as possible this
winter
and before the end of the year we'll
also bring forward a new targeted
approach to support businesses from next
April
but I want to go further
to support people most exposed to high
inflation
around 4 million families live in the
social rented sector almost one-fifth of
households in England
their rep their rents are set at one
percent above the September inflation
rate which means that on current plans
they're set to see rent hikes next year
of up to 11 for many that would just be
unaffordable so today I can announce
that this government will cap the
increase in Social rents to a maximum of
seven percent in 2324 compared to
current plans that is a saving for the
average tenant of 200 pounds next year
this government
this government introduced I thought
they cared about the most vulnerable
[Music]
it's the national living wage which has
been a giant step in eliminating low pay
so today I'm accepting the
recommendation of the low pay commission
to increase it next year by 9.7 percent
that means from April 23 the hourly rate
will be 10 pounds 42 which represents an
annual pay rise worth over 1600 pounds
to a full-time worker it's expected to
benefit over 2 million of the lowest
paid workers in our country and keeps us
on track for our Target to reach
two-thirds of Media Earnings by 2024 and
it is the largest increase in the UK's
National living wage ever
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker there have also been some
representations to keep the uplift to
working age and disability benefits
below the level of inflation given the
financial constraints we face but that
would not be consistent with our
commitments to protect the most
vulnerable so today I also commit to
Upright such benefits by inflation with
an increase of 10.1 percent
[Music]
[Applause]
that is an expensive commitment costing
11 billion pounds
but it means 10 million working age
families will see a much needed increase
next year which speaks to our priorities
as a government and our priorities as a
nation
average a family on Universal Credit
will benefit next year by around 600
pounds and to increase the number of
households households who can benefit
from this decision are also
exceptionally increase the benefit cap
with inflation next year
finally Mr Speaker
I've talked a lot about British values
of compassion hard work dignity fairness
there is no more British value than our
commitment to protect and honor those
who built the country we live in so to
support the poorest pensioners I have
decided to increase the pension credit
by 10.1 percent which is worth up to
1470 pounds for a couple of 960 pounds
for a single pensioner in our most
vulnerable pension on our most
vulnerable households
but the cost of living crisis is harming
not just our poorest pensioners but all
pensioners
so because we've taken difficult
decisions elsewhere today I can also
announce that we will fulfill our pledge
to the country to protect the pension's
triple log
[Applause]
in April in April the state pension will
increase in line with inflation and 870
pounds increase which represents the
biggest ever increase in the state
pension and to the millions of
pensioners who will benefit from this
measure I say now and always this
government is on your side
Mr Speaker there is a global energy
crisis a global inflation crisis and a
global economic crisis but the British
people are tough inventive and
resourceful we have risen to bigger
challenges before we aren't immune to
these headwinds but with this plan for
stability growth and public services we
will face into the storm
there may be a recession made in Russia
but there is a recovery made in
[Music]
[Applause]
commit to our plan today with British
resilience and British compassion
because of the difficult decisions we
take today we strengthen our public
finances bring down inflation protect
jobs we build the first state-backed
nuclear power station for 30 years we
continue the biggest program of capital
investment for 40 years we protect
standards in schools cut NHS waiting
times fund social care cat energy bills
support those on benefits we protect
workers with the biggest ever increase
in the National living wage
and our pensioners on the triple lock
with the biggest ever increase in the
state pension
is a balanced plan for stability a plan
for growth and a plan for public
services it shows that you don't need to
choose either a strong economy or good
public services with conservatives and
only with conservatives you get both and
I commend this statement of the house
oh
I know call
the shutter Chester Checker Rachel
Reeves
[Music]
speaker and thank you to the chancellor
for that statement
so here we are the end of 2022.
three prime ministers
four chancellors and four budgets later
where do we find ourselves
in a worse place than we started the
year
inflation spiraling growth plunging
living standards falling Mr Speaker
Britain is a great country with
fantastic strengths but because of this
government's mistakes we are being held
back
what people will be asking themselves
that the next election is this and me
and my family better off with a
conservative government and the answer
is no
[Applause]
the mess we are in the mess we are in is
the result of 12 weeks of conservative
chaos but also 12 years of conservative
economic failure
growth dismal investment down wages
squeezed Public Services crumbling and
what does the chancellor have to offer
today more of the same
with working people paying the price for
his failure
the chancellor should have come here
today to ask for forgiveness
an apology but no instead he says that
his predecessor was correct in his
analysis at the mini budget the mini
budget that put our economy into free
fall
all the country got today was an invoice
for the economic Carnage that this
government has created never again can
the conservatives be seen as the party
of economic competence
now it's been clear for weeks what they
wanted to do step one blame Global
factors step two pretend the mini
budgets pretend the money budget is
nothing to do with any of them step
three portray the chancellor and prime
minister as the people who can clear out
the best of their party's own makers
and step four attempt to lay some
so-called traps for the labor party
they've even had George Osborne in to
advise them on how to party like it's
2010. but Mr Speaker this isn't a game
this is about people's lives this is
about people's livelihoods it's about
their ability to pay the mortgage their
ability to pay the rent and the ability
to pay the bills after 12 years of
conservative stagnation that has left
our country so much worse off
it's about the fact that when the global
storm hits we are uniquely exposed
because of the choices that the
conservatives
exactly now Mr Speaker nobody doubts
that the covid pandemic and war in
Ukraine have had profound implications
and the whole house is united in its
condemnation of Russia's aggression
problems started before the covid
pandemic and they started before
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
has grown by an average of 1.4 a year
under the conservatives compared to two
one percent
in the labor years before that we are
the only G7 economy that is still poorer
than before the pandemic as the governor
of the bank of England told the treasury
select committee yesterday
the U.S has grown by 4.2 percent since
the pandemic the GDP of Eurozone
countries is 2.1 percent higher and yet
the UK is 0.7 smaller than at the start
of the pandemic we aren't recovering we
are heading into recession as the obr
has confirmed today now the governor
described these differences as dramatic
and a stock
how does the chancellor describe them
and how does he explain them
this is the price of a decade of Tory
choices and economic failure and it is
set to continue with the IMF forecasting
that out of the 38 most industrialized
economies the UK will have the slowest
growth of any of them in the next two
years now the chancellor is saying today
that he will be honest
so let's be honest yeah who one was
talking about cuts to public spending
two months ago and no other Advanced
economy is cutting spending or
increasing taxes on working people as
they head into recession
this government has forced our economy
into a zoom Loop where low growth leads
to higher taxes lower Investments and
squeezed wages with a running down of
Public Services all of which it's
economic growth again and instead of
learning from the mistakes of the last
decade they're simply repeating them we
need to break free from this vicious
cycle of stagnation with fairer choices
and a proper plan for economic growth
now the chancellor and prime minister
are trying to convince us that Britain
faces problems that nothing to do with
them that the mini budget which imposed
a Tory mortgage premium put pensions in
Peril and trashed our reputation around
the world was all just a bad dream it's
their Bobby Ewing strategy
Downing Street as Dallas old cast
members return as if nothing had
happened
possibility and everyone knows it is
long past time that this series was
canceled
and the problem for the British people
is this this is not a dream this is the
everyday nightmare of Tory Britain
Mr Speaker the conservatives would have
us believe that they are not responsible
for the last 12 years of failure
in doing so they take the British people
for Falls
millions are already worried sick about
how to make ends meet and are now facing
the added stress of higher mortgage
payments
the prospect of home ownership becoming
more and more remote and rents going
through the roof
what does this mean
family holidays canceled savings
depleted hopes for the future replaced
by sleepless nights and all of this on
top of the fact that the average worker
is earning less today than when the
Tories came to power 12 years ago the
government has presided over the biggest
wage squeeze in centuries
this was a crisis made in Downing Street
and it is ordinary working people who
are paying the price
now Mr Speaker as I was coming into
Westminster today I read a timely
warning from the police about
pickpockets in the area they warn you
may have an idea of what a pickpocket
looks like but they're far less likely
to stand out in a crowd than you think
they may work in teams to just try and
distract the targets and one of their
tactics is where a thief will appear to
be over friendly while pickpocketing you
now I must report that in the last hour
the conservatives have picked the
pockets of purses and wallets of the
entire country
has deployed a round of scale taxes
taking billions of pounds from ordinary
working people
a conservative double whammy that sees
Frozen tax thresholds and double-digit
inflation erodes the real value of
people's wages
just one of those freezes
in the personal allowance will cost an
average earner more than 600 pounds make
it even harder to make ends meet
at the same time the government is
forcing local councils to put up council
tax now the chancellor seems to have
confirmed today a council tax bombshell
worth 100 pounds for a typical band D
property taking their council tax above
2 000 pounds for the first time
local people including those with
conservative councils will be forced to
pay more because of the destruction that
the conservatives have reached on our
economy and this at a time when councils
are already in Dire Straits because of
cuts by conservative governments now
they probably sat around the tables in
Downing Street thinking that this was
some clever trick but no one is to blame
except the government that's been in
power for 12 years not local authorities
but this Tory government more taxes more
inflation higher mortgages and instead
of tricks and stealth taxes why don't
they have a proper economic plan for
Britain that puts working people at
their hearts and why do they refuse to
have a real industrial strategy that
gives business certainty unlocks
investment and means that Britain can
once again leave the world in the
industries of the future
Mr Speaker the chancellor is trying to
claim that this statement today is fair
yet we learn that of all the things that
he could save from the wreckage of the
Kamikaze budget that he chooses to press
ahead with is their plan to lift the cap
on Bankers bonuses at a time when he's
urging wage restraints for everybody
else how can he remotely claim that this
is bare
and after weeks of will he won't he we
learn today that the chancellor won't
after all
be cutting down on non-doms tax-free
income for millionaires while
millionaire Millions face Frozen tax
allowances and council tax time
how can he possibly claim that this is
fair he refuses to act
and I wonder why maybe that was the only
policy that he can't get signed off by
number 10 down his face
I say if you make your Britain your home
you should pay your taxes
and what about the private Equity
managers earning Millions who benefit
from a tax break on their bonuses which
means that they pay far less tax as a
proportion of their incomes than
ordinary hard-working people
did the chancellor close that loophole
today and make sure that they pay their
fair share of tax he did not he made
ordinary working people pay the price
instead
because Mr Speaker
time and time again we've seen how quick
the conservatives are to raise taxes on
working people now the chancellor has
even compared himself to Scrooge
he's asking working people to take the
hit with less money in their pockets in
the run-up to Christmas but also for
years to come
but if you're a banker a non-dom or a
private Equity manager don't worry
Scrooge hasn't canceled your Christmas
and that's before we even get onto the
energy Giants
after months of resistance well The
Honorable lady says from a sedentary
attack what about taxes well the
numbdoms don't pay taxes that is the
whole point
[Applause]
to the energy
really no I don't pay taxes and that's
before we even get on to the energy
Giants after months of resistance from
this prime minister the government has
finally been dragged Kicking and
Screaming to extend the windfall tax
that labor have been calling for since
Jan
yet they still leave billions of pounds
on the table yeah prophets that are the
windfalls of War yeah
yeah because they have failed to close a
huge loophole that they created that
hands out massive tax breaks to those
oil and gas giants for doing the things
that they were going to do anyway
for those wondering why some energy
Giants have paid no windfall tax in the
last quarter despite record profits and
eye-watering bills for consumers the
answer is the decisions that this prime
minister made when he was Chancellor
confirmed by the current Chancellor lets
the energy Giants off the hook once
again
Mr Speaker the government has announced
plans for energy bills next year but
Bill payers will still see prices go up
next spring leaving far too many people
wondering how they'll make ends meet for
every pound of windfall tax left on the
table people are faced with higher
prices on their bills
and the Tories failure on energy goes
back much further
they closed down gas storage
blocked onshore wind and solar and
slashed support for home insulation now
today the chancellor says that he will
act on Energy Efficiency but I'm afraid
it's all far too late we called for the
insulation of two million homes a year
more than 12 months ago that could cut
bills by a thousand pounds not just for
one year but for every year to come and
they did nothing
insulation levels in 2021 were 20 times
lower than in 2010 because of their
neglect and now he proposes a package
but we have to wait until
2025 for them to act why when people are
facing a Bill's crisis now years and
years will have gone by while he sits
back millions of families could have
been helped and they have not been
[Applause]
and still they block Renewable Power
like unsure wheels that could bring
energy bills down
creates good jobs in all parts of the
country and ensure that Britain can lead
the way in the industries of the future
clean power is the right solution to the
energy price crisis but yet again the
conservatives have failed they have
failed to protect us from future shocks
failed to tackle the cost of living
crisis and failed to take the decisions
in our country's National interest
it is because they have failed to grow
the economy that they are having to
bring forward yet another statement with
tax Rises and spending cuts
the last prime minister and Chancellor
embarked on a reckless Sugar Rush that
abandoned fiscal rectitude and they all
cheered for it but the current prime
minister and Chancellor the current
prime minister and Chancellor had given
up on growth altogether and how do we
know because the office of budget
responsibility has seen their plans and
they've downgraded growth in the months
and years ahead
achieving the levels of growth this
country needs isn't like flipped
flicking on a switch we need a serious
long-term plan to get our economy
growing again
powered by the talents and efforts of
millions of ordinary working people and
thousands of businesses we need a fairer
Greener more Dynamic economy creating
good jobs in every part of the country
in homegrown Renewables in green
hydrogen in carbon capture and storage
with Labor's green Prosperity plan with
a modern industrial strategy where
government Works hand in hand with
business properly fixing business rates
so that small businesses and our High
Street businesses Thrive again and
fixing the holes in the government's
brexit deal to help UK businesses trade
and compete in the world and ensuring
that Britain is the best place to start
and grow a business that is what a labor
government will do
foreign
Mr Speaker while our public services are
struggling and working people are being
stretched the rampant waste and
cronianism from this government
continues a pace
it does not seem to concern the
chancellor that his government dished
out 3.5 billion pounds of contracts to
friends and donors of the conservative
party and the latest prime minister the
latest prime minister spent so much time
when he was Chancellor practicing his
signature for his glossy Instagram
Graphics that he failed to put in place
even their most simple checks on covered
sports that is why the former treasury
Minister Lord Agnew described the
current prime minister's fraud failures
as Schoolboy errors the Prime Minister
left the doors to the vaults wide open
to organize criminals and drugs gangs
they helped themselves to 6.7 billion
pounds of taxpayers money yeah yeah
money that the government is failing to
retrieve yeah and last month and last
month it was slipped out that the
taxpayer protection task force set up to
get this money back
is being wound down
the government's just given up
and the conservatives are turning yet
again to our crucial public services to
make up the money
Mr Speaker the fraudsters may think that
they have got away with it but a labor
government will hunt them down for
everything
[Applause]
the country is sick of being ripped off
by the Tories we want our money back
because of Tory failure our crumbling
public services are set to suffer even
more ordinary people lose yet again
never before have people paid so much in
tax
and yet got so little in return at the
weekend the chancellor admitted that the
NHS was already on the brink of collapse
with seven million people on NHS waiting
lists how much longer will that list get
three in ten people are leaving
Education Without GCSE English and maths
what will this do to our society and our
future economy and why do the Tories
have an ideological objection to putting
VAT on school fees which the chancellor
himself admits will raise 1.7 billion
pounds
by their actions it is clear the
government does not value our public
services or the contribution of those
working in them
and what do we hear today reviews on
schools and the NHS Workforce on social
care and on waste but what we need is
action the time for delivery is now not
time for more reviews
and now we hear
from the chancellor who had previously
said that one of his biggest regrets as
health secretary was failing to fix
social care and today he is further
delayed the government's much promised
social care cap
this is yet another broken promise after
12 years of Tory failure on social care
the Tories have trashed our public
services and the statement today is
proof that they are doing nothing to
turn that around
Mr Speaker the conservatives have
crushed our economy given up on growth
and sent inflation through the roof and
as usual it is ordinary working people
who are paying the price it is a
familiar tune every mortgage they raise
every cut they make every tax they hike
the conservatives are costing you yeah
and what have we heard today yet more
excuses and unfair choices they have
failed to tackle the cost of living
crisis they have failed to show how they
will fix our Public Services they have
failed to show how they will deliver
growth and they have no plan for the
future of our country
everything we have heard today and after
12 long years of Tory failure the
conclusion that we must come to is that
Britain can no longer afford a
conservative government
[Music]
all right
let me start with the chair of the
select committee hurry up bowling
[Applause]
thank you Mr speaker
thank you Mr Speaker today we've
announced tax Rises and spending cuts of
55 billion pounds we can debate the
reasons but to govern is to choose and
she didn't answer the simplest of
questions does she back the need for a
package of this size to bring down
inflation if labor can't answer they are
not fit to govern
she says she says it's the government's
fault but with a made in Russia
recession a once in a century pandemic
higher inflation in Europe bigger cuts
to growth in Germany bigger interest
rate hikes in America to blame this on a
mini budget that was canceled in three
weeks is just not credible
no no Mr Speaker are her facts right she
said the government is making the
recession worse well today the
independent office for Budget
responsibility says we are making it
shallower saving 70 000 jobs
[Applause]
she says this is austerity 2.0
but in the 2010 Parliament
spending fell about three percent a year
in this Parliament even in the next two
years it will rise three percent a year
11 billion pounds for the NHS and
schools is not just more for our Public
Services it's massively more than she
has ever promised
and then she talked about our record
over 12 years so let's do that growth
higher than Germany France Italy or
Japan
lowest unemployment for nearly 50 years
good or outstanding schools up by a
quarter four million more patients in
good or outstanding hospitals in other
words growth up employment up school
stand us up NHS funding up
and because she won't back this package
the British people today know that under
labor it's inflation worse cost of
living worse unemployment worse
competitiveness worse
if we want if we want stability
if we want stability growth and funding
for public services the choice is plan
or no plan we have a plan where's hers
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker and it's uh good to
see The Return of the forecast from the
official office for Budget
responsibility and I think we all
remember why a conservative government
had to set up the office for a budget
responsibility we'll have them in front
of our committee next Tuesday And We can
question uh the underlying assumptions
of the forecast
I welcome the fact that the chancellor
confirmed today that his announcements
go with the grain of what the bank of
England is trying to do in bringing down
inflation that surely is the most
important economic challenge for our
country at the moment
a Chancellor if he could elaborate a bit
more on his thinking
um he's tasked the work and pension
secretary with uh helping those back
into work who have left the workforce
and he's announced very welcome support
for those
um on the welfare welfare system of 900
pounds next year can he talk us through
his thinking in terms of some of those
Cliff edges and incentives to work well
can I welcome my real friends to her
chairmanship of the select committee I
know she'll do a brilliant job and and
she makes very important points first of
all it is essential that we work hand in
glove with the bank of England to bring
down inflation and today the obr
confirmed that inflation is lower
because of the decisions that we take
um and she's absolutely right to focus
on the worrying increase in the
economically inactive that is not just
causing supply chain problems for
businesses but it's also driving
inflation and that's why we're lucky
we've got an excellent work and pension
secretary who is going to make this his
top priority in the work that he's doing
for the Prime Minister and he will bring
his conclusions to this house as soon as
possible
SMP spokesperson Alison Krugers
thank you Mr Speaker well that was the
Alton statement announced by the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt 55 billion pounds
worth of tax Rises and spending cuts
against a backdrop of a recession a wage
squeezed for millions and inflation at
11.1 there were tax Rises as expected
particularly for high earners but also
Millions others of others affected too
plus spending cuts although they were
backloaded until after the next election
which perhaps makes you wonder if they
are ever going to happen at all if the
conservatives won't be in power a couple
of rabbits two with extra spending for
schools and the NHS in the next two
years and benefits and pensions both
said that they would be guaranteed to be
raised in line with inflation well with
us now as usual we are joined by our
political editor Beth Rigby and our
economics and data editor Ed Conway Beth
to you first there was a lot of pitch
rolling before wasn't there about
eye-watering decisions difficult
decisions was it as gloomy as build
well I think the first thing so was
there weren't many surprises in it
because the government actually wanted
to do the opposite to what Liz truss and
quasiquartang had done and as you said
Pitch roll this lay the ground so there
wasn't any surprises that would unnerve
or Ripple the markets or unnerved voters
or indeed uh conservative MPS that's the
first night it was kind of as expected
apart from as you said a couple of
little rabbits in terms of a bit more
spending for schools and a bit more for
hospitals in the next two years but the
big pitch let's go back to the big pitch
on what's really happening in people's
lives and households because that
actually despite all the rhetoric of
this being reasonable and fair that's
where it's going to hit people the first
thing to say is it was indeed 55 billion
of tax Rises and spending cuts but what
the government has done and I've just
got the score card this is where you see
all the numbers of how it all actually
adds up so uh Jeremy Hunt spins it in a
certain way and then you see the numbers
and it tells you what's really going on
in terms of the spending cuts they have
been completely
backloaded to the next Parliament
politically why because the government
can look like it is consolidating at the
public finances but the pain of those
spending cuts will not be felt
potentially by this government given
that they might not be in power post
2025 of the 30 billion of spending cuts
the government have announced if I find
it 21 billion of them end up in 2027 to
28 so you can see exactly what's
happening in terms of the government
back loading that pain causing
potentially a labor government the
difficulties of taking those decisions
on tax and spend if you go back to the
taxation that we are seeing
um 24 billion as we thought was 24.7
billion of total tax decisions and that
has been weighted in part onto business
you've got about 6 billion Ian coming in
from those energy levees you've got this
freezing of Ni employers contributions
that brings the treasury in 5 billion
Baht for all of us freezing income tax
threshold drags millions of people into
higher bans it affects everyone in the
country that plays income tax and by
2027 that is Raising 6.8 billion from
for the treasury and when you look at in
terms of what they've done for spending
in in the short term in this Parliament
yes they've kept the spending envelope
from March
2022 that's about three percent of
spending growth but if you put that
against what inflations are that's a big
spending squeeze on schools and
hospitals and on protected budgets which
is why perhaps the chances decided to
put a bit more money in
um but there is going to be a Spanish
squeeze there's going to have to be
efficiency savings and that has a
knock-on effect for public sector pay so
in terms of how this affects households
you can have income tax Rises for
everyone you're going to have public
sector pay being squeezed and just in
terms of how these decisions are hitting
households the obr report and this is
from Paul Johnson from the ifs digging
this out not me I should say he's
pointing out that real household
disposable income per person is going to
fall by more than seven percent over the
next two years it's the biggest fall on
record it will be taking household
incomes down to 2013 levels energy bills
are going to go up to 3 000 pounds April
2023 a typical household uh paying that
so I think politically what Jeremy Hunt
has tried to do here is take the
conservative party back onto the center
ground acknowledging that he needs to or
wants to protect NHS and education
budgets things that matter very much to
the public uh giving pensioners that
inflation lift giving benefits that
inflation lift giving more support to
households more vulnerable households on
energy bills so that's the nod to
compassion and fairness in the budget
but in reality
what they are dealing with if you have
to make a decision you have to have 55
billion of financial consolidation it's
massive and it's going to be painful and
it's going to be felt by households up
and down the country thanks very much
for the analysis Beth um let's bring
edit now shall we um Jeremy Hunt said
it's all about stability growth Public
Services how do the sons look to you let
me I'll whiz through them first of all
because um and that point actually that
Beth was making uh about household
disposable incomes and put that in so it
doesn't get in the way that's also an
interesting one that we we need to look
at in a moment um but first of all you
know the big numbers uh because you know
really this is a different picture for
the UK economy than it was only a few
months ago let's start with gross
domestic product this is basically how
fast the economy is going and we need to
do this stuff we need to look at how the
economy is doing because it's the first
time we've had at an obr forecast
remember this has been delayed delay
delayed it's the first time we've had an
official forecast from the government
which feeds into everything else uh
since March now last time around this
was what was expected okay in the coming
years so 22 23 and so on let's bring in
these latest figures we've just got from
the government so actually slightly
stronger growth in the year we're in at
the moment but look that's the recession
okay and the obr thinks we are in
recession right now down by 1.4 percent
uh next year compared with an increase
of 1.8 which was the previous
expectation but another thing that's
worth just drawing your attention to I
mean that's the big story first of all
but the thing that worth worth noting is
look these are quite strong numbers in
the future years you know quasi quattang
was talking about wanting to get up to
2.5 percent GDP in the future well we're
kind of at that level so that's growth
recession but actually straight stronger
than expected uh off in the future
inflation I said earlier didn't I that
these number Bars were going to go up
didn't take a genius to work that out I
should say but look there they are 9.1
inflation uh this year at 7.4 next year
so a lot higher than previously expected
but look at this as well look you've got
negative inflation deflation in 2025 so
a big question as to whether uh the
recessionary forces are going to force
that through into the system so that's
interesting too and then finally when it
comes to these numbers The Big Numbers
let's look at borrowing so you've got
public sector net borrowing this is the
total amount the government is borrowing
in these years going out into the future
the higher the bars are the more they
are borrowing uh last time around blue
bars this time around red bars have a
look I'm going to bring them on uh and
there you can see an enormous shift much
more borrowing this year next year and
also also on into the future and this is
the interesting thing talk about
austerity talk about getting that down
but actually in practice much higher
borrowing figures off into the future
than were previously forecast uh back in
March so that is a big change from what
we had uh only a few months ago and it's
worth actually finally okay one thing
quickly I'm going to try and fit this in
because we're talking about Market
reaction weren't we this is the
government bond yield over the course of
the last few hours look it jumped a bit
during the statement okay people got a
little bit nervous around them but look
it's come down quite a lot the
government will be quite pleased by that
we're not seeing that kind of reaction
the scary reaction we saw after the mini
budget so far at least but let's see
what happens uh over the course of the
next few hours because you know the
day's still young and I'm sure you're
going to be keeping track of that for us
lots of analysis still to come with
myself Beth and Ed for that Autumn
statement 55 billion pounds worth of tax
Rises and spending cuts the tax Rises as
Beth was saying you'll be hitting
everybody spending cuts seem to be back
loaded will they happen most of them
coming after the next election but
paying for everyone of course with
inflation at the level at that it
currently is uh now lots more analysis
still to come from us from MPS and of
course from the Independent experts as
well we'll be bringing you that as the
afternoon continues
as we wait for that reaction it is now
one o'clock you're watching Sky news's
special coverage of the Chancellor's
Autumn statement a mammoth plan for
economic stability the chancellor
announces a raft of measures to fill a
55 billion pound black hole
[Music]
there may be a recession made in Russia
but there is a recovery made in Britain
[Applause]
and we
and we commit to our plan today with
British resilience and British
compassion
it's the result of 12 weeks of
conservative chaos but also 12 years of
conservative economic failure
[Music]
but the chancellor warns households will
face increased energy bills High
inflation and tax hikes as the country
is hit by a recession
there will be more though for the NHS
since Jeremy Hunt increases the budget
for healthcare by 3.3 billion pounds
[Music]
the cost of living here in Wolverhampton
where I'll be speaking to business
owners workers and Shoppers about how
the Chancellor's plans will affect their
finances
hello good afternoon the chancellor has
promised to rebuild the UK economy in
his Autumn statement however households
will face increased energy bills High
inflation and tax highest hikes as well
as the country is hit by recession
Jeremy Hunt said he was having to make
difficult decisions to stabilize the
economy that labor Shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves accused the conservatives
of picking the pockets purses and
wallets at the entire country well we
can take a look now at some of the
measures that were announced today
there'll be Energy bill support for
households extended Beyond April for a
further year although the energy price
guarantee and the annual bill for the
average household should we say will be
3 000 pounds that's up from 2500.
the NHS budget is to be increased in
both of the next two years by an extra
3.3 billion pounds
the pensions triple lock will also be
protected pension credit is to rise by
10.1 percent that's worth up to
1470 pounds for a couple and 960 pounds
for a single pensioner
the chancellor also said that working
age and disability benefits will also be
operated with inflation now that is an
increase of 10.1 percent it's a cost of
11 billion pounds
and taxes too a windfall tax on Major
Oil and Gas producers will be raised to
35 up from 25 and as well as this an
energy profits Levy rate of 45 will be
imposed on electricity generators with a
Chancellor saying it should raise 14
billion pounds next year
and to personal taxes too because Jeremy
Hunt also reduced the threshold of the
top rate of tax that means the 45p rate
now becomes payable at 125 140 pounds
that is down from 150 000 pounds
and another rabbit on education the
government announced they will invest an
extra 2.3 billion pounds per year in
schools next year and the year after
well let's take a listen uh shall we to
the chancellor he spoke in the House of
Commons a short time ago
there is a global energy crisis a global
inflation crisis and a global economic
crisis but the British people are tough
inventive and resourceful we have risen
to bigger challenges before we aren't
immune to these headwinds but with this
plan for stability growth and public
services we will face into the storm
there may be a recession made in Russia
but there is a recovery made in
[Music]
[Applause]
commit to our plan today with British
resilience and British compassion
because of the difficult decisions we
take today we strengthen our public
finances bring down inflation protect
jobs we build the first state-backed
nuclear power station for 30 years we
continue the biggest program of capital
investment for 40 years we protect
standards in schools cut NHS waiting
times fund social care cat energy bills
support those on benefits we protect
workers with the biggest ever increase
in the National living wage
and our pensioners on the triple lock
we're the biggest ever increase in the
state pension this is a balanced plan
for stability a plan for growth and a
plan for public services it shows that
you don't need to choose either a strong
economy or good public services with
conservatives and only with
conservatives you get both
Jerry hunt there at saying that his
priorities were stability growth and
public services and saying the
conservatives would show compassion well
in a pretty fiery opening response the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves argued
that the Alton statement would not leave
British people better off she instead
claims the public would still be forced
to pay more because of the destruction
that the conservative party in her view
has caused
the mess we are in is the result of 12
weeks of conservative chaos but also 12
years of conservative economic failure
growth dismal investment down wages
squeezed Public Services crumbling and
what does the chancellor have to offer
today more of the same
with working people paying the price for
his failure
the chancellor should have come here
today to ask for forgiveness
was correct in his analysis at the mini
budget the mini budget that put our
economy into free fall
the country got today was an invoice for
the economic Carnage that this
government has created never again can
the conservatives be seen as the party
of economic competence
uh well with us to analyze the Fallout
of what's been announced today we're
joined by a political Erza Beth Rigby
and also our economics editor Ed Conway
um Beth
it was billed wasn't it as you know
Norton's statement it was all about
difficult decisions all about cutting
spending all about raising taxes and
yeah for the next couple of years at
least does it feel like spending is
perhaps being protected to a level more
than people were expecting
well I think the issue is for the
government and for all of ours is that
inflation is at a 41 year high of 11.1
and yes it's going to fall back slightly
um next year but that is a road in
living standards and it's a road in
public services because everything is
costing more uh to do to to heat schools
and so on
um but what the government has done in
terms of this fiscal consolidation 55
billion pounds worth 24 billion of it is
tax Rises 30 billion of it are spending
cuts uh what the government has done is
they've backloaded the spending element
of this uh into the middle or the late
part of the decade I.E they've pushed it
back they've kicked it back until after
the next general election so yes there
is pain and there will be pain in the
next two years because quite simply uh
budgets will be rising by about three
percent inflation's going up by anything
between 7 to 11 percentage points and
that means that there is of course a
squeeze on public sector budgets and
that will have a knock-on effect for
example public sector pay so it's by no
means pretty but in terms of the bulk of
the spending cuts yes they come if you
look at the scorecard which is how the
government costs the tax and spend
decisions uh the bulk of the spending
cuts are coming in 2027 to 2028 that's
what
21.5 billion of them so they are kicking
the problem into the next Administration
where it could well be a labor
government with that problem not a
conservative government
um but there are stealth tax rises in
here as well and the government has in
the run-up to this Autumn statement
stress that there will be you know
they've leaked a lot of it nearly all of
it really stressing that there will be
windfall taxes on energy companies
that's coming in at about 5 billion uh
freezing thresholds for ni contributions
National Insurance constitutions from
employers that's raising a big five
billion so there's Big Ticket tax rises
in here but the really big one are the
stealth taxes for all of ours those
paying income tax by 2020 seven to eight
freezing the thresholds uh from next
year uh right through to 20 27 28 the
government will get 6.8 billion so
that's 6.8 billion of contributions from
everyone paying the basic rate of tax
and that is indeed a big sum but the
other thing that is really standing out
in all of this is the effect that
inflation rise in energy bills is having
on households and when you look at the
obr they're the ones that in that put
out the independent uh forecasts it says
here that household incomes are going to
see a 7.1 percent uh fall in household
incomes it's takes it to the lowest
level since 2013 so there you have it
that's the real life squeeze everyone is
going to be feeling uh in the next
couple of years and that is going to put
huge pressure clearly on the government
they have sought to ameliorate some of
that pain you saw the energy package uh
there it wasn't clear whether Jeremy
Hunt would extend the energy price
guarantee that Liz truss promised for
two years which he then rode back on but
from April 2023 everyone will get
support taking the average household
Bill to about three thousand pounds a
year but that's still a lot of money and
there is more support yes there is more
support uh for those on benefits that
inflation relift in benefit income which
will help those on the lower incomes and
of course that benefit that inflation
linked lift for pensioners as well but
the big picture is that everyone is
going to be paying more taxes everyone
is going to be feeling a squeeze on
household incomes and there are
definitely no winners in this Autumn
statement at all yeah very important to
remember I think you know if we do talk
about any rabbits in the Autumn
statement the overall picture as you say
is still very Grim I mean this is 55
billion pounds of fiscal consolidation
and it can be spun in whichever way by
the government but that is a lot of
money of tax Rises and spending cuts and
this was a government that ate we ago
said it was going to do the biggest tax
spending tax cuts in five billion of
taxes tax cuts in 50 years it's
completely schizophrenic from you know
the the diet the pendulum swim it
swinging from that to this in eight
weeks where the public thought there
were going to be loads of tax cuts and
they were going to enjoy the benefits of
that to its swinging background to
saying actually you're going to be
facing tax Rises and I wonder how people
will take that and react to it and if
you know the job partially of the Autumn
statement was to restore fiscal
credibility after what we saw eight
weeks ago with you know the markets
tanking with the bank of England having
to step in with emergency measures
have they done that well let me go
through some of those numbers and
actually that that point that uh Beth
was making about household disposable
incomes you know that that's one that uh
there's a pretty scary chart we can show
you just in it in a moment but let's
start with a big picture because
obviously we've just had the latest
figures from the office for Budget
responsibility on the state of the
economy and that is a big deal we don't
get this uh many times it's only every
six months or so and this was much
delayed these bars are just showing you
how well we're doing each year it's
gross domestic product it's kind of the
most comprehensive measure we have of
how much income we're generating as a
country so when they're in positive
territory that's generally speaking good
news and the higher they are the more
we're earning as a country that lot was
the last time around okay so those bars
were March now have a look at what we've
got this time around this is the latest
figures look slightly higher actually
they see a little bit of a surprise
there but slightly high a bit more of a
bounce uh this year than previously but
just look 2023 is the one to focus on
here
the obl thinks we're over in recession
so does the Bank of England there you
can see it a fall of GDP of 1.4 in 2023
uh a pretty big four there but not
necessarily lasting as long as some
people had previously thought the bank
of England thought this potentially
could last really long not the obr they
think relatively weak growth uh in 2024
but then actually pretty strong growth
in 2025 26 27. remember quasi quatang
was talking about wanting to go up to
2.5 percent Trend rate of growth we're
not all that far from that at the moment
are we so there we have growth gross
domestic products what about inflation
obviously prices rising really fast at
the moment last time around the obr I
thought it was going to Peak at maybe
7.4 percent that was the rate the number
they had for 2022. what about now well
look at these bars up to nine percent
over nine percent uh this year then 7.4
but here's another interesting thing
okay inflation getting down to below the
bank of England's Target the bank's
supposed to keep inflation around two
percent but look it's below Target in 22
24 and then in negative territory in
2025 that's 2025 there so you're talking
about going from a really high
inflationary period back there to
deflation basically that's a big shock
and what does that underline it
underlines the fact that we're living
through this roller coaster and also
we're going through a bit of a crunch
right now which means that people don't
necessarily spend as much and prices
potentially go down borrowing I just
want to talk about briefly because this
is really important as well obviously
we're talking about the you know
question of how much the government is
going to contract uh in terms of their
spending but have a look at this this
shows you borrowing of what was expected
last time around so about 100 billion
pounds this year look at the forecast
this time
look at those bars much higher this year
much higher next year what you've got
there is obviously all the different
measures including most notably the
energy price guarantee very expensive
measures indeed pushing up borrowing for
the next couple of years but look at
what happens afterwards okay look at how
much higher those red bars the latest
numbers are to the blue bars in the
future years as well it's not like
borrowing is going to be getting down to
where richly soon that forecast it to go
back in March these are big changes so
despite the talk about austerity
actually you've got a government that is
borrowing a lot more over the course of
the next years that being said of course
there's inflation to bear in mind but
even when you look at percentage of GDP
numbers which kind of adjust for that
you're still talking about much higher
bars off in the future so that's kind of
interesting the other thing to notes and
this this goes back to the point that um
we're talking about just a second ago
household disposable income now this is
a chart that the obr had last time
around and
this one really matters the higher these
bars are the better we're all doing so
that's how high our how much our
disposable income the amount we have in
our pockets to spend is rising each year
and what you can make out look we're
going back to 1956 here six here what
you can maybe just about make out is
that over this period most of the time
it's in positive territory we've got
these nice big blue bars but look at
what was expected last time around so
last time back in March this is what the
obr was expecting and that bar there was
the lowest it had been in history okay
now keep an eye on this bit here because
we're talking about the next few years
that's the year that we're basically
going into at the moment so keep an eye
on this and I'm going to bring on the
latest numbers we've just got from the
obr
look at that
look at those bars no longer is this the
worst year for household disposable
income in modern history it's the worst
two years for seeing our household
disposable income basically Contracting
so that
is frankly utterly depressing you know
that is one of the most depressing
charts I have seen and unfortunately it
was depressing last time the obr
produced this chart back in March but it
just got a lot depressed more depressing
because they just added you know an even
worse couple of years there and that's
the backdrop here partly it's obviously
a story about what's going on in Ukraine
partly it's a story about the fact that
you know we are going through a really
difficult time in the UK economy as well
so I'm afraid you know that's really the
big story and that goes back to
um to what Beth was talking about a
second ago
alongside all of the kind of fiscal bad
news there's this kind of assessment for
the economy that it's going to be one of
those recessions that's not just it's
not like the kind of financial crisis
recession it's not like the recessions
we've kind of used to from recent years
it's a recession that really will hit
you in your pocket you know because our
spending power our disposable income has
just contracted our ability to pay
and that is kind of depressing I'm
afraid and it's you know it's difficult
you can't really put a gloss on that
um so yeah that's the latest I'm afraid
one of the most depressing charts you've
seen that's not the words that you want
to see lately haven't you had yeah it's
not not standing out for the right
reasons thank you both for your analysis
we'll be back uh in a moment at 4 30
just to remind you you will be able to
ask your very own questions on how the
Autumn statement is likely to affect you
uh we'll be holding a q a with a
personal finance expert Gemma Godfrey
that's at 4 30 this afternoon live on
Sky News so do get your questions over
now the chance renounced the cap on
average household bills will increase
from 2 500 pounds to 3 000 pounds from
April that's the average household we
should say
today we set our country a new National
ambition by 2030 we want to reduce
energy consumption from buildings and
Industry by 15 percent reducing Demand
by this much means in today's prices a
28 billion pound saving from our
national Energy bill or 450 pounds off
the average household bill
this must be a shared Mission with
families and businesses playing their
part
but so will the government play our part
in this Parliament we're already
planning to invest in Energy Efficiency
a total of 6.6 billion pounds
today I'm announcing new funding from
2025 of a further 6 billion pounds
doubling our annual investment to
deliver this new National ambition our
commitments to the British people is
over time to remove the single biggest
driver of inflation and volatility
facing British businesses and consumers
so my right arm will friend the business
and Energy Secretary will publish
further details on our energy
Independence plans and launch a new
Energy Efficiency task force shortly
lab business presenter Ian King is in
the city for us and Ian will be talking
a lot about the depressing picture for
household uh budgets and household
incomes but it's a rocky time for
businesses as well isn't it what do you
think they'll have made of the Autumn
statements
well there are some winners and losers
uh Sophie among businesses in this
budget I mean obviously the showstopper
announcement was the extension of the uh
tax on oil and gas uh produces profits
uh that dates the actual rate of
Taxation on North Sea oil producers to
75 which is pretty eye-watering and
obviously there was a 45 tax also levied
on electricity generators it's worth
pointing out that shares in most of
these companies are actually higher as I
speak that is partly because they've
been absolutely spanked over recent
weeks as it became apparent that the
Johnson was first of all going to hit an
electricity generators and then
potentially extend the taxes on North
Sea oil and gas producers so whilst uh
they've they've certainly not had the
news that they would have wanted from
the budget from the Autumn statement the
share price reaction suggests that a lot
of that bad news had already been priced
in now what was uh fairly good news was
for the insurance sector and I mean this
is quite technical nerdy stuff but it
was uh it's nonetheless worth talking
about which is a solvency too now these
are the capital rules affecting the
insurance industry they dictate the
amount of capital that the insurance
companies have to retain on their
balance sheet it was an ey eu-wide
measure and there's been a lot of
discussion since the UK left the EU as
to how you might reform that what is
interesting is that the treasury appears
to have overalled the bank of England's
recommendations here in terms of how how
much it could relax these rules the
insurance companies will be very pleased
about this because this is a way of
essentially releasing more Capital into
the economy enabling the insurance
companies to invest more in projects
such as infrastructure so on the whole
that ought to be good news for growth
and it's certainly something that the
insurance industry as I say has been
calling for the other winners uh
interestingly from the awesome statement
are the is the banking sector and uh
this uh really relates to the fact that
uh for many years now George Osborne put
it in place some years ago there's an
extra taxation on the profits made by
the banking sector now because call
operation tax is being increased by such
a significant extent the uh the the
extra levy on the bank's profits has
been lowered uh that is so they weren't
facing a really uh eye-watering level of
Taxation had the chancellor left that in
place uh you'd have seen the uh taxes on
Bank profits being hiked up to as high
as 33 percent so Mr Hunters actually
tweaked that lower to reflect the fact
that he's raising Corporation taxes it
means that the bank's own but on balance
will still be paying more in uh taxes
than they were but not as much as they
potentially were facing for say for
example you're seeing Lloyd's banking
Group shares slightly higher on the
session right now in terms of some of
the other measures well he's really
picked the pockets of small business
owners it's got to be said obviously
there's that uh reduction in the amount
of dividends that you can take tax free
that will also hit uh millions and
millions of small investors who who hold
shares directly outside of a nicer
you're also going to see obviously that
reduction in capital gains tax
allowances as well and again that is
something that hits small business
owners in particular so uh I suspect
they will not be too happy you've also
on the other hand though seen uh some
potential uh further extensions in uh
business rates relief the hospitality
sector giving that two cheers they still
want to see an overall route and Branch
reform of business uh rates so uh that
is uh something that we'll wait further
news on in terms of the broader Market
reaction was pretty much uh quite to be
honest with you the uh Equity markets
the ftse 100 very little changed uh
before and after uh Mr Hunt's speech and
likewise you actually saw a slight drop
off in UK guilt yields UK government
ious UK government bonds that's an
implied borrowing cost nowhere took you
through all of the borrowing figures
well actually the UK's cost of boring
has actually Fallen very very slightly
on the back of what Jeremy Hunt has
announced there likewise the pound more
or less unchanged right now on the on
where we were before the chancellor
started speaking
uh Ian thank you very much for uh the
update in there talking about the
business picture but really of course uh
the story in many ways is that full
indisposable householder income the last
eight years of living standards growth
wiped out effectively at Sky's Sally
Lockwood is in Wolverhampton where
business owners and Shoppers have been
listening to what the chancellor has
announced today Sally what's the
reaction bin
oh what's really interesting isn't it
that obr assessment that disposable
income is going to fall by around seven
percent over the next two years well
many people here simply don't have that
disposable income left they're already
struggling to make ends meet we're in
Wolverhampton as you say it's got a
strong industrial Heritage we're at the
former HQ of Chubb locks which was built
more than 120 years ago it was turned
into a retail space But even a cinema
which has been operating here for around
30 years closed just two weeks ago today
there are certainly already the shoots
of recession being felt uh here but I
can bring in three people who can speak
with a lot more knowledge than me on
what people are going through here in
Wolverhampton and that is Gail Reynolds
and Stephanie Leo now you both work at
the Stratton Street Methodist Church
community center and we've also got
Sarah Morehouse with us who's the CEO of
black country Chamber of Commerce thanks
for speaking to us I'm just going to
start with Gail and Stephanie first
explain to me what the community Unity
center does and what support you're
offering to people at the moment
okay so it's a very very busy Community
Center it's set in the heart of
Wolverhampton in one of the poorest
areas in Wolverhampton it's open six
days a week providing a variety of
community services to support age groups
from from birth through to senior
citizens we do lots of things that you
would expect in a community center but
because of the cost of living crisis
we've had to take on some additional
services so for instance at the moment
the food bank is incredibly busy we've
also opened a community shop to try and
give people access to Goods at wholesale
prices to help with the cost of living
and in this day and age I find it hard
to believe that also we've had to become
a warm space so that people who are
struggling with just putting the heat in
on know that they can come into a safe
environment that's warm they can get a
warm drink something to eat and a bit of
a social I was reading earlier some
pretty frightening reports about how
people have disconnected from the power
grid altogether because they're so
worried about bills what sort of
problems are you hearing so I work
Monday with our parents that starts to
say here's stories of parents who are
limiting their history and reducing them
out to food that they used to just to
feed their children so it's so very
difficult for some of my parents at the
moment yeah I should say that the
chancellor did of course announced that
they were going to extend that help for
energy bills to households and
businesses Beyond April from